a estas alturas ya estamos super
acostumbrados a ver funciones definidas
como hd y es igual hay al cuadrado o
funciones definidas de la forma f de x
igual a raíz cuadrada de x ahora hay
muchísimos tipos de funciones y en
particular las que vamos a ver ahorita
son funciones que están definidas
podríamos decir que por partes
ok 1º definimos cómo se comporta en un
intervalo luego definimos cómo se
comporta en otro intervalo y así nos la
podemos seguir y este tipo de funciones
se llaman funciones definidas por partes
aunque bueno también lo podemos llamar
funciones definidas por pedazos o por
trozos pero bueno el chiste de estas
funciones que vamos a ver ahorita es que
se definen por pedazos ok lo vamos a ver
en unos momentos aquí mismo tenemos la
gráfica de una función definida por
partes si te fijas en este intervalo de
aquí la función
constante por acá y luego cuando
llegamos al menos 5 salta hasta acá y
del -5 al menos 1 es otra constante y
después en el -1 vuelve a saltar y llega
hasta acá abajo nunca y en este otro
intervalo de las equis toma otro valor
constante
ok como podemos observar tiene estos dos
saltos y aquí lo que vamos a hacer es
ponernos a pensar cómo describir a esta
función con la anotación de las
funciones ok si este es el eje x y este
de aquí es el eje y igual a efe de x
como describimos a esta función lo que
tenemos por aquí
efe x
a ver podemos observar que hay tres
intervalos en los que vale cosas
completamente diferentes entonces
necesitamos mucho espacio y vamos con el
primer pedazo
este pedazo está en el intervalo de
menos 9 a menos 5 gray pero como tenemos
aquí un círculo abierto sin el relleno
eso significa que en este intervalo no
estamos incluyendo al menos 9 ok solo
estamos incluyendo a todos los números a
la derecha de menos 9 hasta llegar a
menos 5 y si incluimos al menos 5 porque
tenemos este círculo relleno aunque hay
entonces el intervalo en el que se
define este pedazo es el intervalo menos
9 menor que x menor o igual que menos 5
porque no incluimos al menos 9 no lo
incluimos y si incluimos al menos 5 si
lo incluimos ok esto de aquí es el
intervalo y en este intervalo la función
vale menos 9
-9 podría llegar a ser un poco confuso
tener aquí dos nueves pero no hay que
confundirse este es el valor que toma la
función en todo el intervalo y este
menos nueve de aquí es donde inicia el
intervalo ok y recordando es súper
importante que aquí tengamos un menor
estricto y no un menor o igual porque si
tuviéramos un menor o igual eso
significaría que en este intervalo
también estamos incluyendo al menos
nueve y entonces la función también
tomaría este valor de aquí y tendríamos
que tener este circulito relleno pero no
lo tenemos relleno por lo cual este
intervalo no incluye a menos nueve y
ahora vamos con el siguiente intervalo
el cual va de menos 5 sin incluirlo
hasta menos 1
menos 5 menor que x menor o igual que
uno menos uno y en este intervalo la
función vale 6 aunque es una función
constante en este intervalo la constante
6 y de aquí justo en el -5 tenemos un
salto desde menos 9 hasta 6 y como estos
pedazos son constantes hasta podríamos
pensar en un escalón y es por eso que
otro nombre para este tipo de funciones
definidas por partes en las que todos
los intervalos toman valores constantes
se llaman funciones escalonadas por esto
de que podría aparecer un escalón ahora
es súper importante que aquí donde
sucede el salto en -5 la función tome
únicamente un valor aunque esté bien
definida porque lo que pasaría si aquí
tuviéramos un menor o igual si este
intervalo también incluyera al menos 5
aquí este circuito estaría relleno
y la función en -5 podría tomar seis y
podría tomar menos nueve y eso no está
padre porque entonces ya no sería una
función para cada valor de x debemos de
tener únicamente un valor de fx y no dos
como tendríamos aquí entonces no podemos
incluir al menos cinco en este intervalo
aunque es súper importante que si
tenemos una función definida por partes
sepamos exactamente en cuál de los
intervalos cae el menos 5 para no tener
este problema de no saber si f de menos
5 es menos 9 fm 56 porque f de menos 5
sólo puede tener un valor en algunos
casos puede llegar a suceder que menos 5
o cualquier otro número esté en dos
intervalos pero en esos casos el valor
de f de menos cinco en cada una de las
partes tiene que ser el mismo ok
bueno vamos con el último
intervalo que va desde menos 1 hasta 9
menos 1 hasta 9 aquí está la equis y
como podemos ver aquí tenemos un círculo
abierto por lo cual no estamos
incluyendo al menos uno recorre todos
los valores hasta llegar al 9 y también
incluye el 9 ahora es súper bueno esto
de que tengamos un -1 estrictamente
menor que x porque aquí en esta parte ya
estamos definiendo cuánto vale la
función el menos 1 ok si es que está
súper bien que tengamos un menor
estricto ahora en este intervalo cuánto
vale la función pues vale menos 7 aunque
menos 7
y listo ya terminamos ya escribimos la
definición de esta función que teníamos
gráfica da por acá y otra cosa que me
parece muy interesante aquí es que
podemos observar lo útil que es la
notación de las funciones en fin espero
que te haya divertido la verdad yo sí me
he entretenido muchísimo con estas
funciones